it's official e3 is back again for 2021
it's going to be june 12th
through 15th however big changes are
happening
not just in terms of how the show is
going to be run but also who's taking
part so i've got the console crew
together
to chat through what this all means i'm
lucy james joined as usual by
playstation pro tomorrow hussein
tickets please we are now boarding the
e3 hype train
and xbox expert jordan may it's way too
early for the hype train tam
it's way too early it's only april
it is never too early for the hype train
and honestly it's just nice that the
news is out there like because all of
this stuff was happening on april 1st
and no one really knew what was
happening so it's nice that we've got
the official announcement from the esa
um who are the folks behind e3
let's talk about it because first of all
off the bat there were a lot of
rumblings about what e3 was even gonna
be this year
last year it was the quote unquote
summer games mess where
everyone was running events it lasted
the whole summer this time around
it's that short e3 window again and
actually there are some big companies
involved a lot of speculation that these
big companies
because they've had success doing their
own thing weren't going to be back for
e3
so jordan can you run us through this
list of the companies who will be
in e3 2021 sure so
the big list is nintendo
capcom oh yeah konami ubisoft
take two warner bros and i have never
is it coach media or koch media club
it's [ __ ] it depends on where you're
from like
if i've never actually pronounced its
name out loud everyone knows what it is
no one wants to say it media
say it but also
it's the jolly green giant it's gonna be
xbox too
which is honestly so let's let's talk
about that we've got this statement from
big phil
here time do you want to read out this
tweet from big phil uh
big phil has said that he is glad to see
the gaming industry coming together
again in june
for a digital e3 this and other summer
events
are proof that our industry is strongest
when we work together
looking forward to sharing what we have
in store this summer
you get an xbox and you get an xbox and
you get an xbox
so i think i think the big surprising
thing here is that yeah
xbox and nintendo have agreed to take
part in e3
um sony has not we'll talk about you
know so
so the people who are missing what sony
ea activision blizzard sega
bandai namco and square enix now if you
look at the list of all of the companies
a lot of them have had success doing
their own things like square next has
started doing their own nintendo has
obviously led the way with direct
activision blizzard they just had
blizzcon line
xbox and nintendo being a part is such a
weird
thing for me to get my head around
because xbox has like just proven that
they don't
need e3 do any of these companies need
e3 well
i mean yes and no you could argue that
xbox kind of needs e3 if for no other
reason like look at the last showcase
that xbox had that four
hour indie showcase extravaganza like i
think they need someone like the
organizers of e3 to be like xbox
scale it back scale it back give us a 45
minute
presentation and like structure it in
these ways like again like to your point
some of these companies i think
are bigger than e3 and they don't
necessarily
need e3 but until xbox figures out like
how to
actually give a compelling live stream
because it just
isn't there in the same way that
playstation nintendo are i think it
needs something like e3 just to focus
its vision
i think jordan is incorrect
and xbox doesn't need e3
i think xbox wants e3 um
and interesting to a degree i think
we're gonna we're team big phil here i
think what he says there
there's an element of that being true i
think that it's important to him
and xbox as a company that this kind of
event takes place
um you know you have this global kind of
event where everything comes together in
one and it is a big showing and it does
mean that
a lot of their initiatives and a lot of
their um
kind of games they're on front and
center and they get to be a
part of mainstream media mainstream
media doesn't
know or care about nintendo direct
it doesn't know or care about the
playstation direct or the xbox
showcases they know the bbc knows what
e3 is cnn knows what e3 is
all these big companies know what e3 is
so to a degree they want that to happen
also i think the other part that makes
them want
e3 to happen is i believe it is the case
i might be speaking
our attorney needs to be double checked
here i think there's a significant
number of
companies or executives at these
publishers
that are on the esa board and they have
a vested
interest in making sure e3 happens to
some degree
i can't remember if phil is on it but i
know
xbox had some representation in years
past so to that extent as well
there are certain companies that want e3
to happen nintendo has a big presence at
e3 always
um and i think they want it to happen
one to get some normality too because it
does have that feel good
story event where the gaming world is
coming together and three because
big big media will look at e3 big big
media is less likely to look at
nintendo direct and xbox showcase
if you're doing an all digital event and
it's just all
live streams like this is it the same as
the normal e3 that's happened
in past years like we're talking about
almost a completely different event here
not to the maybe general public but to
the developers and publishers behind the
scenes this is like a
completely different deal that's the
thing i think we're just taking
different elements from e3 and
especially different elements that have
become more prevalent especially with
you know jeff keeley doing his coliseum
e3 you know having those more in-depth
chats
um there's been more of an emphasis on
live streaming stuff and so i think to a
degree this is an extension of what e3
was going to become
but i think the important thing that was
definitely buried the lead a little bit
was that e3 2022 will be in person again
which
time to your point about the esa people
are going to want to be involved this
year and i'm sure the conversations with
the esa and all these companies are like
well if you want to be on the show floor
in 2022 when we're back
doing this in person you need to work
with us in some capacity in 2021
and that's not to say that you know next
year at e3 there won't be
an activision there won't be a sega on
the show floor it just maybe that's not
high in their list of priorities right
now they're maybe re-evaluating what
in-person shows are gonna look like
and honestly like e3 2019 the last quote
normal one
you know i don't i mean sony wasn't
there i don't think activision blizzard
were on the show floor
um so it's a weird
shifting show and it's been shifting for
the last few years
this to me i feel like i just i just
love e3 and i'm excited that more people
get to experience it
same i love me and e3 and i think it is
very much a case of that like
people are also making bets also kind of
gingerly
putting a few chips down for the future
of e3 and the future of gaming events
like who knows if you know e3 in a way
in a shock move comes back stronger than
ever
you don't want to be in a position where
oh man everyone is into e3 now but i
remember
i uh gave the head of the esa two middle
fingers as i left the room
you don't want to be that person you
don't you know you need to
make sure that you're kind of keeping it
sweet keeping those bridges
there instead of burning them down um
but yeah e3 hype train
the easiest home chain but i mean we
talked about this on console crew 2 or
it's like
and jordan to your point where it's is
this e3 there are to be
pieces of e3 that just don't translate
to an online-only environment and that
is going to be
you know getting hands-on with stuff
there were rumors
that they were talking about doing
online demos but it looks like
they haven't mentioned any of that so
either it's still being worked out it's
been dropped completely
um but it is i mean it is gonna be free
you aren't just
you're just not gonna be able to play
the games i mean jordan you know
how does that how does that sound to you
like still being able to experience
everything but not be able to play stuff
uh it doesn't
irk me as much as just the fact of just
not being able to really
speak to other people in person the
aspect of e3 that for me makes e3 e3
is actually getting to talk to the
developer in person to talk to these
people that i've never
met before long time friends that i just
haven't seen in a really long time
and reconnect and like enjoy gaming
together and
kind of getting to understand what this
new
project is what this new game is by like
seeing the excitement in like a
developer's eyes as they finally get to
talk about it
but you just don't get talking to
someone over uh
a webcam um and so not getting
hands-on wow absolutely
he's really done i can't actually see
you all i'm looking
into a camera there's no face there to
see
to your point like not being able to try
the games like that is
that sucks like uh being able to try the
game itself has also been
a crucial part of e3 but for me that's
not
the most important aspect that i feel
like we're going to be missing out on
this year
i don't think it's impossible like you
know we we have existed
in this hellscape for a year and a half
now and we have
done remote hands-on gameplay
i played cyberpunk before it was out um
and i was nowhere near a event like a
convention hall i was know an std
project we did it
there are feasibly ways for publishers
and developers who are either involved
in e3 or doing stuff around
that period um and there are avenues for
them to give people like us
or anyone really if they want to access
to these games
and to play them it's not in the most
ideal scenario but it is a possibility
there
um so the other thing that doesn't
translate to online uh
e3 is 20 hot dogs that are
disgusting and not e3 food is so
expensive
yeah and if you bring in food they're
like
what are you doing where'd you get that
they'll tackle you to the more prices
get that bringing a five dollar sandwich
in here
get out of it get out of here and pay
for your 15
orange all right well we will obviously
have all the latest on
e3 um we're not even really sure what
the
what the event itself is gonna look like
but in terms of press conferences
hands-on impressions gameplay whatever
comes from e3 we'll obviously have it
right here on gamespot and we're also
gonna be doing our play for all event
like we did last summer so
a mix of developer interviews charity
streams the whole shebang
uh so make sure to like this video
subscribe to gamespot and we'll see you
next time
bye bye train
choo choo
[Music]